INVOLVED WITH TRADE POLICIES.
>> DO YOU WANT A MEDICAL DOCTOR?
JUDGE JEANINE: HERE TO TALK
ABOUT THAT AND MORE, THE
ASSISTANT TO THE PRESIDENT ON
TRADE AND MANUFACTURING.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
THAT WAS -- I WAS GOING TO SAY,
WE ARE NOT INTERESTED IN GOING
INTO OUR CORNERS.
BUT LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION AS
IT RELATES TO THIS
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE.
I TAKE NO POSITION ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER.
BUT WHY IS IT SO ANIMATED WHEN
IT COMES TO THIS?
>> I THINK IT’S THE NEVER
TRUMPERS, THE TRUMP HATERS,
LEFT-WING MEDIA, ANYTHING HE’S
FOR THEY HAVE TO BE AGAINST.
OF COURSE, THIS IS A DECISION
BETWEEN DOCTORS AND PATIENTS.
BUT IF YOU GO TO THE FOOD AND
DRUG ADMINISTRATION EMERGENCY
USE AUTHORIZATION NOTICE, IT
SAYS ALTHOUGH LIMITED SCIENTIFIC
FOR US AVAILABLE, IT’S
REASONABLE TO BELIEVE
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE SULPHATE MAY
BE EFFECTIVE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF STUDIES
OUT THAT SUGGEST EFFICACY FOR
THERAPEUTIC VALUE AND ALSO
PROPHYLACTIC VALUE.
WE HAVE TESTS IN NEW YORK AND
DETROIT AT FORD HOSPITAL.
LET ME TELL YOU WAY DID LAST
WEEK SINCE THE TASK FORCE
SATURDAY.
THE TASK FORCE UNANIMOUSLY
APPROVED SURGING HYDROXY INTO
THE HOT ZONES.
MY TEAM, TEAM TRUMP, BASICALLY
GOT 19 MILLION DOSES OF HYDROXY
FIRST INTO FOUR OF THE HOTTEST
ZONES, CHICAGO, DETROIT, NEW
ORLEANS AND NEW YORK.
THEN WE WENT TO ADDITIONAL
CITIES DOWN LINE, BALTIMORE,
WASHINGTON, HOUSTON.
AND ALSO IN ADDITION THE
VETERANS ADMINISTRATION ASKED
FOR A MILLION DOSES.
AND DOD WANTED ABOUT A MILLION
DOSES AND WE GOT THAT TO THEM.
THERE IS DEMAND OUT THERE AND
THERE IS A PROTOCOL.
THE PROTOCOL IN THE FDA.
IT’S CLEAR WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
IT’S A FIVE-DAY PROTOCOL.
YOU TAKE A DOUBLE DOSE THE FIRST
DAY, THEN FOUR DAYS A SINGLE
DOSE.
WE’LL SEE WHAT THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE SAYS AND I WILL GO BACK
ON WITH THAT GUY AND WE’LL DUKE
IT OUT AGAIN.
JUDGE JEANINE: IS THERE A
COMPETITION?
WE ARE WAITING FOR THE TESTS,
THE VACCINE.
IS THERE SOMETHING ELSE?
IN MY OPEN I PUT IN A SOUND OF
THE WOMAN WHO IS THE DEMOCRAT
FROM DETROIT, A MICHIGAN
REPRESENTATIVE WHO SAYS THANK
GOD FOR DONALD TRUMP MENTIONING
THIS.
ONCE I GOT ON THE HYDROXY I WAS
FINE.
>> YOUR OPEN WAS SPOT ON.
IT’S LIKE THE NEVER TRUMPERS,
HE’S FOR IT SO WE HAVE TO BE
AGAINST IT.
IT’S A SLIPPERY SLOPE THEY ARE
ON.
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE AT THE FRONT
LINE TELLS YOU DOCTORS AND
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ARE USING
STUFFED TO PREVENT THEM FROM
GETTING SICK.
SCIENCE HAS GOT TO A POINT
ENOUGH WHERE IT’S REASONABLE FOR
THE FDA TO APPROVE EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION.
THERE ARE A MILLION DOSES OUT
THERE AND THE REST OF THE WORLD
ARE FIGHTING FOR THE REST OF THE
DOSES AND SOME WON’T EVEN LET IT
GO OUT THEIR BORDERS.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON WITH
HYDROXY AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE PROVED
ABSOLUTE RIGHT AGAIN.
JUDGE JEANINE: AND I THINK THAT
THE INTERESTING THING IS, WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT IT’S PART OF AN
FDA PROTOCOL.
THAT’S PRETTY SERIOUS.
BUT WE’LL WAIT TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
BUT IN LINE WITH THAT, THERE ARE
AS WE A TRY TO FIGHT THIS VIRUS,
AND THANK GOD THINGS ARE GETTING
BETTER.
WE COME TO RECOGNIZE THERE ARE
CERTAIN TREATIES AND AGREEMENTS
WE HAVE WITH OTHER COUNTRIES TO
GET PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT AND VENTILATORS AND
WHATEVER ELSE THERE MIGHT BE.
AND THEY ARE NOT ACTUALLY
DELIVERING PURSUANT TO THAT
AGREEMENT.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US IN TERMS
OF WHERE WE GO WHEN WE ACTUALLY
OPEN UP AGAIN OR EVEN BEFORE WE
OPEN UP?
>> MY MISSION HERE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE 24/7 IS TO FIGURE OUT IS
HOW THE SUPPLY CHAIN DELIVERS
THE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT LIKE
VENTILATORS TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THIS WAR AGAINST THE VIRUS.
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS I DID
WAS BREAK DOWN THE 30 DIDN’T
THINGS YOU NEED TO TREAT A
CORONAVIRUS PATIENT.
WHAT WAS SHOCKING TO ME WAS
VIRTUALLY EVERYTHING ON THAT
LIST CAME FROM OFFSHORE.
THE PROBLEM IN A PANDEMIC IS
WHEN YOUR SUPPLY CHAIN FOR YOUR
MEDICINES AND MEDICAL SUPPLIES
ARE OUTSIDE YOUR BORDERS.
WHAT WE SEE IS COUNTRIES ACTING
LIKE NATIONS.
THEY PROTECT THEMSELVES.
THERE IS OVER 75 COUNTRIES THAT
HAVE IMPOSED SOME SORT OF EXPORT
RESTRICTIONS ON
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND THINGS
LIKE MASKS.
IF WE LEARN ANYTHING FROM THIS
CRISIS IT’S THE LESSON OF DONALD
TRUMP.
YOU NEED SECURE BORDERERS AND
YOU NEED YOUR MANUFACTURING
ONSHORE.
OVER TYPE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE CAN MANUFACTURE EVERYTHING WE
NEED ONSHORE.
THERE IS A COUP WAYS TO DO THAT.
IT’S IMPERATIVE THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT AGENCY BUY AMERICAN,
THE VA, HHS, THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE, THEY BUY LAND
QUANTITIES OF DRUGS AND
EQUIPMENT AS IN MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID.
IT’S IMPERATIVE GOING FORWARD
THAT WE BUY AMERICAN WHEN WE
CAN.
LAHR WRITE KUDLOW AND THE
PRESIDENT HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT A TAX BREAK WHERE YOU GIVE
100% TAX BREAK ON INVESTMENT.
JUDGE JEANINE: I HAVE MARCIA
BLACKBURN WHO WILL TALK ABOUT
THAT.
SHE IS THE NEXT GUEST.
WHEN DO YOU THINK WE CAN REOPEN
THIS ECONOMY?
>> THAT IS THE TOUGHEST DECISION
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND ANY
PRESIDENT WILL EVER HAVE TO
MAKE.
LET ME GIVE YOU A QUICK
PERSPECTIVE ON THIS.
HERE IS THE PROBLEM.
YOU HAVE GOT THE PUREST MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TAKING THE
POSITION THAT THE WAY TO
MINIMIZE LOSS OF LIFE, THE ON
WAY IS TO KEEP THE ECONOMY AND
SOCIETY SHUT DOWN UNTIL THE
VIRUS IS ADVANTAGE -- IS VANQUIS
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED
PARTICULARLY FROM THE CHINA
TRADE SHOCK AND HOW IT AFFECTED
THE MIDWEST COMMUNITY, WE
LEARNED THAT AN ECONOMIC SHOCK,
A CHINA VIRUS ECONOMIC SHOCK
WILL ALSO KILL AMERICANS.
WE LEARNED THAT FROM WHAT WE SAW
IN THE MIDWEST.
WE SAW HIGHER DEPRESSION RATES,
HIGHER SUICIDE RATES, HIGHER
MORBIDITY.
WE SAW AN EPIDEMIC OF OPIOID
DEATHS.
WE KNOW THE VIRUS KILLS, AND WE
KNOW ECONOMIC RECESSIONS AND
DEPRESSIONS KILL.
SO THE TOUGH DECISION THE
PRESIDENT WILL BE MAKING IS TO
HAVE TO WEIGH THE BALANCE TO
FIGURE OUT WHICH PATH DOES MORE
DAMAGE.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE ARE GOING TO
DO EGG TO PROTECT PEOPLE AT THE
FRONT LINES OF THIS.
TO THE EXTENT WE CAN GET THINGS
LIKE ANTIBODY TESTING FOR
INFECTIONS, THERE ARE TOOLS
DEPLOYED OUT IN THE FIELD THAT
WILL HELP US BETTER GET PEOPLE
BACK TO WORK.
IF YOU HAVE SOMEBODY TAKING AN
ANTIBODY TEST AND HAS THEM, THEY
CAN GO BACK TO WORK.
JUDGE JEANINE: PETER NAVARRO, WE
ARE OUT OF TIME, BUT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEING BACK ON